I'm Peter Stamper and I'm Heidi Stan
heart and we had nine hundred and
eighteen thousand three hundred eleven
dollars in debt now we have zero his
time being from the Northeast you would
think that oh it's the it's the
financial capital of the world people
have lifestyle figured out not
necessarily financial planning or
financial management figure it out I
think most people are broke in the
Northeast but they have a big lifestyle
we were in the Northeast and we were
living in Connecticut and we relocated
to Cincinnati Ohio in 2008 and we had
big eyes the houses were big so we went
big we bought the really beautiful house
fifty five hundred square feet or
mortgages on two houses four cars and
summer credit card loans right we saw it
all we wanted it all
and then in 2010 Peter got he got let go
know everybody has a moment on the cross
where you're like this is bad you feel
like you are just working so hard and
and you're not getting ahead and we
could have continued but it was way too
high of a percent of our income and we
were in a mess I had to completely
rewire my thinking on how I valued
myself having all of that debt is like
having somebody hold you underwater
it is a all-out panic fight it's messy
it's ugly it's scary you were like I
have got to get out of this BAM
no debt love it I started listening
today listen to him briefly two three
weeks look for a class this is just
exactly what I needed once we got going
and we were committed we just I didn't
care anymore
I didn't care what the neighbors thought
or what anybody thought
this is what you get when you downsize
from five to two thousand four feet this
all needs to find a new home so we're in
the process of deciding if you guys were
interested like a feedbag chair for you
here we got some chairs we were just on
a mission everything everything we had
garage sale we sold Heidi's BMW we sold
the Honda then we sold the house in
Connecticut then we sold the house and
Cincinnati if you're a good boy you get
to keep one toy this is mine 66 DTO
we are not we are regular people right
and it's a proven recipe for success and
you just stick to it and there is a
definitely my little nightmare here we
got chandeliers you got chandeliers
washer/dryer wreaths the following it's
it's winning and small steps
that's the trick so my question would be
did you win financially this week
today's Friday did you win this week did
you spend more than you made and if you
can win this week and you can do that
four times in a row you can win this
month and and if you win this month on
your diet on your on your workout on
your finances on your relationship if
you can win this month and you can do
that 12 times you could win this year
you just work at it you're passionate
about it you commit to it and you go
being out of the debt has paid dividends
in many other ways throughout our
relationship and throughout our family
you feel the weight you know so free now
I feel free three two one
you